Carlos is in New York hey Carlos welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hi babies hi
Chris thank you for taking my car
sure what's up so I am 25 years old I'm
currently working for the baby ship -
and I'm actually looking to propose to
my girlfriend I'm calling you to see
when you think it would be that I'm
currently walking through baby said -
and I was I was I wanted to check with
you to see if you had any guidance on
big brands Dave Ramsey has any guidance
on how much you should I should spend on
a ring and if I should put off proposing
until I'm through baby step - no you
should not you should propose
immediately well hold on the second date
Carlos how long have you held this woman
we've been together for almost nine
years oh good lord
it's time to paint or get off the ladder
that's ridiculous nine years all right
here we go all right here we go so the
jewelry store will tell you three months
of your income on the ring but common
sense will tell you one month what do
you make 95 thousand a year
whoo girls gonna get a good ring all
right so I mean you know one month's
income what's your take home pay for a
month for a month
yeah would tell you somewhere around
like six seven thousand I think okay you
know I spend that much I'll be
comfortable spending that much I think
honestly I'm looking to be dealt with
Biggi said to within this year so yeah I
would stop them stop your baby step to
immediately save up the money for the
ring go buy the ring whatever it is it
needs to be under five grand and okay
five five or six something like that and
that's your bet your cap and go buy the
ring and then restart your plan okay
okay thank you
cuz she might wake up and realize that
you've been procrastinating too long you
don't want this to happen
at nine years you better go get a ring
mostly we weren't school together and
things like that okay yeah no just pick
sorry buddy but hey if you found it if
you found the good one go take care of
it but like Dave said get back to the
baby steps what ends up happening Carlos
says people will pause for one reason on
another and then they end up finding
three to four of the reasons you've been
intentional and you don't want this debt
coming with you into your marriage so
get the ring get back on that on track
be very intentional moving forward and
delete this debt from your life yeah let
me say well Chris had a different way we
you it's okay if the debt comes with you
into the marriage but it's not okay if
it comes with you in the marriage
because you didn't address it
yes that's what he's saying but we're
not we're not saying you have to be
debt-free to get married you asked that
question or let's go and be clear on
that we don't tell people that we don't
tell people that to be debt-free that
babies we don't tell people they have to
be debt-free to get married but you do
have to be on the same page you have to
be an agreement that we're going this
way with money man you need to be that
whether you're debt-free or not so that
that's the whole plan and way to go
congratulations let us know when you get
engaged we want to celebrate with you
that's awesome man
very cool